hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today pairs well
with fava beans and a nice key anti we
got some hannibals on the show not
physically in studio that would make me
and my delicious brains very nervous but
we will be consuming the careers of both
mads Mickelson and Anthony Hopkins
digesting their finest roles in medious
moments they've done other stuff than
just playing that famous cannibal guy in
fact their resumes prove that these
thespians can pull off the villainous
twist or a heroic turn with equal a plum
it's mads Mickelson taking on Sir
Anthony Hopkins Mickelson V Hopkins mads
Anthony not to be confused with Matt
Anthony a delicious hot sauce from Van
Halen bass player Michael Anthony It's
the Best of Both Worlds today and on
versus we tend to celebrate wonderful
careers by making them compete against
each other in one corner it's mads
Mickelson who's cried tears of blood in
a Bond film built a flaw into the Death
Star in Star Wars and played Hannibal
Lecter to much Acclaim on the small
screen in the other corner it's Anthony
Hopkins who's been a tortured
ventriloquist the father of asgard's
finest hunks and played Hannibal Lecter
to much Acclaim on the big screen it
could all come down to who can eat more
nah we're not gonna Fourth of July Joey
Chestnut Kobayashi this are we
oh boy here's how we'll determine a
winner round one box office round two
Tomato Meter slash audience score round
three iconic characters round four
memorable moments and then we'll do a
wild carton round that I hope doesn't
involve who is the better cannibal but
that is going to be the placeholder for
now if I don't come up with something
better but knowing me like I do it's
dicey but there you are dear viewer and
before we begin here's a friendly
reminder that I Mark Ellis would never
eat you but I will wrap up your comments
thoughts and takes on this Stellar
versus matchup hit that like button do
we is there still a like yeah there's a
like button hit it and buckle up for
mads Mickelson Esquire taking on Sir
Anthony Hopkins so apparently Anthony
was knighted by the queen you know the
one from the Netflix show in 1993 but
then he might have renounced it as part
of the process when he became an
American citizen in the year 2000 so do
we still call him sir I'm only human
well perhaps I made a mistake yes I
think we should I call my personal
trainer sir and dude's 10 years younger
than me now that's really interesting I
don't want to upset Tony Hopps remember
the time he played that guy who thought
he was a gorilla an instinct you don't
want to make him mads Mickelson versus
Anthony Hopkins right here right now
let's get it on that's it
um
anyone wants to play Pocono someone's in
a hurry round one box office yes these
are two highly regarded actors who have
astonished their peers with dazzling
performances and wowed critics for their
commitment to craft but in order to
carve out a career in this Biz you got
to put butts in seats preferably when
the chairs are aimed towards a super
giant screen you know like in a movie
theater now we're getting the hang of it
these guys can play just about anything
including a gorilla Anthony but in terms
of box office might it never hurts to
have a few Blockbuster franchises under
your belt and both of these boys have
been featured prominently in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe also known as MC
Universe which sounds like an early 90s
rapper Anthony struck comic book Gold
first appearing as king Odin Thor's
Pappy in 2011. Thor would go on to
hammer 449 million dollars on Earth then
in 2016 mad stepped up to battle doc
strange and his inaugural outing raking
in 646 million but they kept making
those thores the Dark World grabbed 644
million then Ragnarok hulked out to the
tune of 850 ml that's good enough to top
Anthony hopkins's entire filmography in
terms of cheddar accrued it's strange
Maybe
who am I to judge mads His Highest
earner of all time was another little
property called Star Wars and his
benevolent scientist helped Rogue one
drum up over a billion bucks worldwide
but these fellas they weren't done
franchising just yet mads was a seminal
Bond Baddie in Casino Royale which took
home a cool 594 million and did you
remember he was in Clash of the Titans
yeah that movie cracking 493 million
dollars followed by Fantastic Beasts the
secrets of Dumbledore's 404 million
dollars in Magic that's probably the
last time I'm going to call that movie
by its proper title I have fun with the
Fantastic Beast flicks because if I
don't who will
sinful Anthony Hopkins isn't a one
franchise Pony either he was in a
Transformers movie the one about
medieval times and his portrayal of Sir
Edmund Burton in the last night grossed
over 600 million dollars enjoying this
round Autobots because that Tomato Meter
round it's a comment I do so love
perfect timing he also popped in to
narrate How the Grinch Stole Christmas
in the year 2000 and that film hoot its
way to a 345 million dollar take another
story based on a book Noah made 352
million dollars and The Mask of Zorro
sliced up 233 million back in 1998. ooh
he was in Dracula too as in a good guy
Van Helsing and the 1992 film also based
on a book now that I think about it sunk
hits fangs into 215 million dollars in
cash register Jingles seems like he had
won more franchise to brag about oh
right the whole doctor thing but you do
not want Dr Lecter making a house call
you want to zoom with them knock
yourself out his first foray into the
sick world of Hannibal was in The
Silence of the Lambs which chewed up 275
million dollars then a decade later
Hannibal would gobble up 350 million and
for dessert red dragon consumed 206
million I'm glad that was this last one
because I am out of descriptive verbiage
and I'm already past my carb allotment
for the day
all told Anthony Hopkins got a few
decades Head Start in his movie career
would it pay off in this round kinda he
loses out to meds if we look at the
average box office receipts accounting
for all of his movies Hopkins stands at
about 115 million dollar per film mads
is at 205 million but Mickelson's career
total is 3.6 billion against hopkins's
6.3 billion so which way do we lean and
by we I mean me I guess sometimes I go
with the gross total other times I
prefer average here I feel like both
actors have done plenty of tiny films
that weigh down their box office
averages and since the total was helped
in large part by franchises the one
property that you can say needed that
person the most was Hannibal some of us
saw a Manhunter with Brian Cox as the
good bad doctor but the role is still
synonymous most with Hopkins and his
Trilogy even more so than the recent run
Mickelson had on television it was good
and highly rated but not enough to steal
a point in the first stage Anthony
Hopkins maybe a sir definitely gets the
round one point and he goes up one to
nothing
thank you Barney
two Tomato Meter slash audience score
all right with penalize some
Transformers movie shall we that wasn't
a nice way to welcome you all around two
it is the rad where we look at both the
critical takes and the masses opinions
on the fine job applications of Anthony
Hopkins and mads Mickelson you must be
very proud
proud as I can be in short this round
will answer the question are those
beasts really fantastic oh it's beyond
special we'll get to them but first we
honor a deliciously evil turn that's a
bad choice of words because I'm actually
talking about mads Mickelson as Bond
near do well the shifra the guy plays a
mean hand of Poker and the critics were
smitten Casino Royale stirred up a 94 on
the Tomato Meter and a 90 on the
audience score a rare double 90 Club
member as is Open Hearts from 2002 and
2012's the hunt which saw mad score a
best actor dub at the prestigious Cannes
Film Festival
Anthony Hopkins he's also got a few
90-90 entries including the father at 98
on the Tomato Meter and 92 percent with
the audience he won an Oscar for that
flick and then he has Silence of the
Lambs which has twin 95 on two scales
the Tomato Meter and the audience score
and you know what if memory serves he
also won an Oscar for that movie who do
you think you are PAL Meryl Streep he
has been nominated four other times so
he's got a way to go to catch our queen
of Cinema but she wasn't in the Elephant
Man from 1980 must you no she wasn't
Anthony was and it's a 92 percent on the
TM and 93 with the audience ooh last but
oldest is the Lion in Winter one of
hopkins's earliest film roles and the
1968 talkie is at 90 percent on both
measuring sticks okay so we got some
momentum going here further chewing
along fresh ground for tone tone is
Amistad at 78 percent Nixon at 75
percent and Bram Stoker's blood sucker
at 77 red dragon is fresh at 69 dude
percent but curiously Hannibal the
middle of his three elector films the
meat in that sandwich is rotten at 39
huh what happened red dragon came out
like the next year and it's fresh with
the victims I mean audience resting at
62 percent and for sir Lord Mickelson
he's got fresh Fair like Doc Dr Strange
at 89 percent Rogue one at 84 percent
and at eternity's gate has a 79 percent
and for what it's worth Hannibal the
show is another member of the 90-90 club
a better host would have mentioned that
along with his movies but I write stream
of Consciousness baby that was rude Miss
Jones the series run can boast a 92
percent with the critics and in 94 with
the audience but it can't be all
sunshine and roses and tasty Meats
there's some rotten on these fellas
filmography's underbellies and so let's
lift it up and I'm just about done with
that metaphor real talk I got super
excited looking at mads Mickelson's
Tomato Meter list and seeing Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny on it it
doesn't have a score the movie comes out
in the summer probably not even finished
yet but pretty good trailer right let's
hope it's not rotten like say Clash of
the Titans at 27 or 2011's three
musketeers at 26 percent or even King
Arthur's 31 percent that's the one from
2004 not the guy Richie joint fantastic
base the secrets of the stud from the
holiday is also rotten at 46 percent but
the audience dug it to the tune of 83
percent and for the record the holiday
featuring Jude Law is also somehow
rotten at 51 on the Tomato Meter you
monsters it's a great holiday movie
Anthony Hopkins is now hoping his
mediography doesn't weigh him down but
he does have that Transformers movie to
deal with the last night is 16 e Bad
Company with Chris Rock was good as far
as I remember but it landed at just 10
percent in the veggie patch and at 35
percent with the crowds oh no and
Alexander is also at 16 yikes okay time
to save it with Instinct the movie where
Hopkins is convinced he's a primate ooh
27 but fresh with the audience at 67
percent well done crowds ooh Anthony
Hopkins was also in free Jack where
Emilio Estevez let me get this right
Estevez plays a NASCAR driver who Grooms
into a dystopian future and Duels with
Mick Jagger that's got fresh written all
over it or maybe it doesn't 26 you can't
win them all Anthony but how about this
round look Anthony Hopkins is one of the
all-time great actors that has ever
inhabited planet Earth or Asgard may it
rest in peace but his average Tomato
Meter score is rotten or I'll be nice
and say fresh adjacent at 55 percent
which is actually not that bad some hits
some misses how about the audience score
58 okay so he's in the ball game can it
top the bloody tears guy you know if I
wept plasma I might break bed too with
shifra if you need a hug come on in it's
not your fault and speaking of the show
Breaking Bad I have a cool story about
that later stay tuned meanwhile Jen
urso's daddy came here not just to play
but to win he's got a fresh 69 average
on the Tomato Meter that pleases Bill
and Ted 69 dudes
and his audience average is 70 sure he
hasn't had the output of Anthony Hopkins
yet who has besides you Meryl we get it
you're good I feel like mads has been
around long enough to make this round a
fair fight and he scores a punch round
two goes to Mickey and we're tied one to
one
it belongs to you round three iconic
characters let me ask you an honest
question dear audience this Show's been
airing since what 1981. so we've known
each other a while so here it goes who
is the first character you think of when
I say the name Anthony Hopkins still
probably Hannibal Lecter right maybe
Odin possibly Elder Zorro and The Ellis
household it's obviously the guy who
thinks he's a gorilla but it's cray cray
that after all these years nay centuries
packed with wonderful Hopkins
performances Hannibal is still the first
dude that comes to mind
is that the case with mads I actually
don't think so I might lean towards this
Casino Royale bad guy or his Star Wars
good guy so this rap could get pretty
competitive even with the massive head
start Anthony got due to that whole
being born earlier thing will Mickelson
earned points for disappearing into more
roles or will it be Hopkins for playing
the most memorable actor topping mads
this one's gonna be a hoot I might have
known about The Silence of the Lamb
starring this legendary actor back in
1992 but for little Mark that year was
all about Dracula Van Helsing might have
been the first time I saw Hopkins and
went I think this guy's got a future
It's a Wonderful movie Bram Stoker's
Dracula that is certain star accents
aren't the best but wow does Van Helsing
inject some energy into that bloodstream
it's a horror movie and a Gothic romance
and we're starting to feel the weight of
hundreds of years of loneliness then
comes Mr five-hour energy Anthony and we
get some fun one-liners awesome action
and a battle plan to off the undead
hairdo once and for all
vampires do exist if you held a cross to
my head I couldn't tell you if that
character was based on any sort of real
person but apparently there really was a
president named Richard M Nixon what did
the m stand for ask Bart Simpson's
neighbor not Flanders the other one
Hopkins landed a best actor nod for
portraying the embattled president who
was juggling everything from the heights
of the Space Race to the lows of Vietnam
to the sneakiness of Watergate now we
all know what Nixon looked like his
mannerisms he was in the TV era and
Anthony still nailed it I mean I could
probably pull off Millard Fillmore I
don't know what that guy's quirks were
but to stick the landing with Nixon
that's impressive but mads Mickelson has
plenty of range too you see back when
Star Wars used to be movies and not TV
shows they'd asked to cast way ahead of
time than us fans would guess who was
gonna play who Rogue one gets heated up
the guy who took no mercy on James
Bond's manhood books apart and we all
thought that's the next great galaxy far
far away villain but instead he played
Galen urso the imprisoned father other
of our protagonist Jen urso and he's
warm compassionate he's a family guy he
did what he had to do to protect them
and in doing so was commissioned to
build the Death Star he was a genius
along the lines of an Intergalactic
Oppenheimer and his screen time elicits
a tender side that most audiences may
not have seen yet speaking of y'all see
that trailer for Nolan's Oppenheimer
movie holy crap is that going to be
something special the versatility with
both these gents continues Mickelson is
an accomplished dancer started out
pursuing ballet for goodness sakes so a
role in a movie like another round is
the shoe that fits 2012's The Hunt is
yet another side of his Brilliance
there's a reason he took Hand by storm
that year and his sheer will survive in
the film Arctic is literally
breathtaking conversely Anthony Hopkins
thought about going full time with the
piano in his youth but decided to
instead become Loki's stepdad there's a
few acting roles in between like in
Magic I am obsessed with this movie
Hopkins earns overtime playing both a
ventriloquist and voicing the dummy
lovingly called fats but not the way you
want to voice a puppet how do you like
it I think it's going to be terrific
what's with Gang Green Blue Cross Street
position
[Music]
the thing takes over and it's a
precursor to our horror movie Buddies
like Chucky Chucky's bride Annabelle and
welcome Megan to the party plus I'll say
it here Buzz and Woody they're cute but
get those demons away from my bedroom he
knocks a classical piece like Titus out
of the park elevates Sosa material like
in The Wolf Man and his turn in the
father is astounding as a patriarch
stubborn to ask for assistance as he
gets older it's heartbreaking an oddly
life affirming in a weird way the
movie's good Hopkins is legendary but we
do love seeing these two go down a
darker path did you know Anthony Hopkins
once played Hitler it's a film called
the bunker and I'm not sure there's many
historical figures that hops can't pull
off mads is a threat to steal every
scene in Casino Royale but I feel like
Hannibal Lecter would also enjoy
torturing James Bond ooh let's get that
movie in the hopper both gentlemen excel
in the role of the Diabolical cannibal
Hopkins presents us with a quiet
unnerving presence a few explosions of
anger where we see why he's locked up in
a place like that and he holds Clarice
in the palm of his and Jody Foster is in
good company there because the rest of
the audience watching is entranced as
well like Hopkins Mickelson can inject a
Sly intellectual wit to the proceedings
and in both cases we see the Brilliance
and the horror of this dude
you intend me to be my own Last Supper
yes
charmer he'd be a fun friend you know
power around with during the day but
just be gone before nightfalls all told
Anthony Hopkins filmography is just too
stat for Mickelson to keep up thus far
but mads is on Pace to beat his
predecessor is level before it's all
said and done Anthony Hopkins wins round
three today and goes up two to one a
census taker once tries to test me
I ate his liver with some fava beans
round four memorable moments and here's
another phase where Anthony hopkins's
resume can really factor in the dude's
been searing memories into our yummy
brain tissues for decades yet he's still
about as prolific as any Young Buck
working today and in a round it will be
won by the actor that's given us the
most Thrills chills and noteworthy
sequences he's got to be the favorite
but mads Mickelson has a puncher's
chance here why the Art of Dance look at
mads Mickelson goat did you know that
was part of his skill set I mentioned
that he trained in ballet among other
movement disciplines and watching the
movie Another Round makes me feel like
not only will this guy win a few Oscars
he should be hosting the damn ceremony
of course we came to know him from his
stoic poker playing in fits of anger
against International super spies the
quiet boiling cauldron that is La shifra
at the poker table gives way to an
all-time Bond villain turn that includes
ingenious torture methods and tugging at
James's heartstrings Casino Royale is a
top 5 5007 movie from me and the primary
villain is a huge reason why I have two
pan you have a 17.4 chance of making it
straight if it's action you like mads
has plenty more to offer the shootout in
Riders of justice is gnarly and there's
lots of violence and polar not to be
confused with arctic where he's just
trying to survive when his plane crashes
into the frozen tundra that is
definitely not Lambeau Field ooh y'all
seen Valhalla Rising not that Valhalla
here mads plays a guy who in little sing
an optometrist opts to just bludgeon
people slightly more to the story I'm
told I won't ruin it for you here but
it's brutal and do not get on the wrong
side of Mr one eye doctor strange
further showcases mad's ability to wreck
many shops and Rogue one shows his
tender side the scene where Jin and
Galen get to reunite may be brief but it
packs an emotional while up and remember
Luke Skywalker Han Solo Princess Leia
none of them get to be heroes or denied
Chewbacca his medal if Galen erso hadn't
built that flaw into the Death Star I
mean he probably could have made the
exhaust a little bigger but then maybe
red leader Nails the proton torpedo shot
and is the hero but nope it just
impacted on the surface
it was me
it was me here's a movie I hadn't heard
of after the wedding it's a Danish film
where the Soulful mads dealing with his
ex one scene in particular the can we
talk moment is astonishing if you've
ever had a Kennedy talk moment you know
incredible after that dude as is Anthony
Hopkins in another world he could have
tickled the ivories while mads did some
soft shoe on stage but they both got bit
hard by the radioactive acting bug you
can't find the inevitable
beautiful and Hopkins has proven over
his illustrious career that he can do it
all stirring soliloquies like an Amistad
inspirational speeches like his I'm
going to kill the bass scene in The Edge
and his mentoring of the next generation
of Zorro even back when he's beginning
his film career he could hold his own
with anyone including Katherine Hepburn
and Peter O'Toole in the line in Winter
I guess it shouldn't be that surprising
simply because prior to that Hopkins
worked as the understudy a few times to
Sir Lawrence Olivier who as far as I
know remained a night the rest of his
days I still don't know if Anthony's a
knight or not but if england does need a
battle-tested warrior give Van Helsing a
buzz
I love this performance so much he just
barges in alleviates all doubt that
vampires do in fact exist and he goes
the distance with Dracula I also might
send Hannibal into combat as long as he
promises not to eat anyone on our side
as Dr Lecter the iconic lines like his
beckoning to come closer or to the side
dishes he prefers while munching on
liver not the kind from an animal remain
as haunting now as they were in 1992. he
also has a wonderful tet with Edward
Norton and red dragon and enjoys
um more Cuisine courtesy of Ray Liotta
in the film Hannibal
that smells great all forever championed
his performance in Magic y'all watch
that movie it's Bonkers but if I'm being
honest I think of the father now more
than anything else when Hopkins is
brought up probably recency buys and
it's nothing against the classic 1999
film Instinct but it's such an emotional
ride he takes us on the regrets the
longing and actual line in Winter eking
out as much Independence as he can
muster before the chapter of this life
closes it's one of the more recent
examples of why Hopkins is such a legend
and while mads Mickelson could be on his
way to such status Hopkins is still the
King of the Hill Hopkins wins the round
and goes up 3-1
hey
jolly good and now it's time for the
Wild Card round Story Time with Uncle
Mark the more mathematically proficient
of our viewers will see the score is
three to one and realize that this is
the final round so mads Mickelson kind
of needs a miracle to pull out a victory
I've never given out two points in any
one round of verses not even a King Kong
or Ewoks or Old Yeller so mass is going
to take an L here but before we close up
shop remember how I mentioned Breaking
Bad here's the story so is Brian
Cranston and a gun and Company closed
out the final season of what would be an
all-time television Triumph it seemed
like everyone in the world was furiously
racing to catch up on past Seasons you
know binge watching including Anthony
freaking Hopkins after doing so he
penned a letter to Brian Cranston which
I will now perform excerpts from I'm
nervous now it's my turn to do a
monologue and Tony might actually be
watching here we go Dear Mr Cranston I
just finished a marathon of watching
Breaking Bad from episode 1 of the first
season to the last eight episodes I've
never watched anything like it brilliant
your performance as well Walter White
was the best acting I have seen ever
from what started as a black comedy to
send it into a Labyrinth of blood
destruction and hell it was like a great
Jacoby and Shakespearean or Greek
tragedy if you ever get a chance to
would you pass on my admiration to
everyone thank you that kind of work
Artistry is rare and when once in a
while it occurs as in this epic work it
restores confidence you and all the cast
are the best actors I've ever seen that
may sound like a good lung full of smoke
blowing but it is not it's almost
midnight out here in Malibu and I felt
compelled to write this email
congratulations and my deepest respect
you are a great great actor best regards
Tony Hopkins he called himself Tony
Brian Cranston gets to call him Tony I
probably can't anyway I just thought it
was a really cool story about Talent
paying it forward in an all-timer making
the Next Generation feel special that's
good stuff Anthony Hopkins gets the win
on versus and honor I'm sure will be
taken with the same level of Pride as an
Academy Award and God right for that
next Generation mads Mickelson is in
there he's got range for days we all
can't wait to see what's next in store
for him that does it for this episode of
versus I get to clock out but you the
viewer step right up hit me up on social
media at Mark Ellis live and all of us
here at Rotten Tomatoes at Rotten
Tomatoes thanks for watching versus I'm
Mark Ellis and I will not put the lotion
in the basket
thank you